he woke up sensing something a calamity
was coming hello everybody my name is
markiplier to stop the calamity he only
had and welcome to 400 years again by
script welder who if you don't know he's
made a ton of really cool games in the
past now this game in particular is
interesting because it's about the
passage of time not about time travel
it's about literally watching the world
change around you as you are wading
through time so I'm waiting here for BAM
that exactly that to happen
see I'm literally a stone monster and
I'm wandering the world trying to solve
the problem of this calamity I don't
know what the calamity is because we've
just reached as far as I've ever played
this game before
sometimes you overcome an obstacle he
had to climb a tree I think it's what it
said up in ours oh no it's not big
enough but if I wait I'm an avid avid
avid avid avid avid a bit of an okay I
don't want to wait too long cuz then I'd
run out of time and time is very
important when you only have 400 years
sometimes the tree was in the wrong
place what does that mean how am I gonna
solve that I am oh oh that's cool
oh that's so cool okay press e to plant
the chestnut got it we wait again
god is so trippy just the idea of being
able to literally stay in one spot and
not care it's like one uh in Futurama
when a bender was sent back in time over
and over again to try to receive our
steel a bunch of crap from the past that
was a weird episode admittedly and I
waited for the perfect time for this
winner to set it now this game what uh
it's not a new game I would like to say
that right now is actually made sorry
everybody
he saw the people were hungry okay what
does that mean
I guess I'd freak out if there was a big
stone monster everywhere I suppose I
could have gone and got a chestnut what
are you doing in the wall there all
right whatever
it doesn't matter anyway this game came
out a while ago and I've never played it
before I looked it over when I was
looking at other script welder games and
I had no idea what it was about
okay so wait a minute willow wait was I
was I supposed to be able to do
something there where am I going to get
food and am I gonna bring it back I mean
I got all the time in the world there's
400 years me just walking around like
this I ain't gonna do nothing so wait do
I did I did I mess up
gonna mess up someone tell me something
sometimes to overcome an obstacle II
needed a helping hand oh I gotta go back
and help the people okay BRB BRB ooh ooh
ooh I got grain I had no idea there
would be grain over here I got the
grainy screen I'm on my way back maybe I
could have just gone over the thing but
hey I got green now these guys couldn't
cross the lake to get some green I guess
I was too stupid to figure out myself so
I don't know I'm complaining about them
Hey ha ha I got food he plant grain
Oh see take land ah see take plant take
plant take plan I'm I did my best I did
my best I did my best everybody
I got you wheat oh maybe I'm done
oh I'm an idiot I did it that was it it
didn't say they were hungry anymore
IRA Lillian I'm just here like that rock
statue staying for a long time after he
planned all this wheat and he's just
like every year I wake up and like hey I
need a helping hand everybody who's
gonna give me a helping hand
anybody oh oh
all they're developing is a society
that's so cool oh there we go
ha ha yeah it just takes a lot of
patience it takes it took all that
waiting made my brain go soft but I'm
there okay that's so crazy I had to wait
60 years for that to happen
Wow holy crap
I also wait it'll wait too long just
like I wasted time going back and forth
like what's going on if I just patiently
waited after planting all the grain
maybe I would have been somewhere oh I
need to wait in the middle of the lake
okay I got it it's so crazy it's such a
cool concept oh okay I gotta get this
right on the first try right here baby
woman yes I know I'm amazing I know I
know
all these years of maybe ones or Stevie
funk okay so where am I headed now how
am I gonna stop this horrible calamity
how did I sense it in the first place
these are all questions that I'm
assuming you're gonna be answered okay
am i oh that is not fast
Wow that is the opposite of fast well at
least I turned in my years of waiting
wow that is not fast holy crap that is
slow okay yeah oh man Dwight I stopped a
wait longer
Wow I do okay maybe that's enough yes
okay holy crap I waited and waited 56
years or 55 55 years I waited 55 years
per stalactite and stalagmite to grow
goodness that's so long the messes with
your head does the idea of just what is
that what is that the net oh well I mean
well damnit maybe I could've just waited
on the surface a civilization would have
been there by now all right let's see
what's over here has a civilization
become Wow they've uh they've advanced a
bit you're still scared of me you should
be there's a calamity coming there's a
calamitous calamity wait what oh here we
go
just not perfect oh it's so pretty
it's so cool it's so cool
god it's so cool it's a concept that
I've never really explored in the game
before and I don't know if like there's
been another game that has exported I'm
not saying this is the only one this is
like so cool wait a minute oh I see as
the seasons go by on oh my chestnut
mergers nerd there it is it's in the
right spot that's what matters
it's in the roids stat yeah yeah yeah
okay here we go
and Lebowski right
Oh lovely waiting Hey
Oh but ever never ever Dibby Dibby Dibby
Dibby de boi I can't believe I can't
believe this calamity is gonna be so
patient and wait for me to wander all
the way across the world in only 400 he
was getting close to his journey's end I
was
what
Oh
Oh do I go down there
all
what is going on why am I going down
here
why but I barely got through any of the
years wait a minute there had to be
something else
ah gotta be those another there's
another thing ah there's another there's
another side of the volcano I didn't go
down I have to know I think I know I
think I know I might have already done
something wrong because the tree to go
get chestnuts again because I thought
there might be a thing that I need to
grow on the other side was gone so this
might mean that I'm not able to if it
did that I will be mad I will be mad all
ooh
damn at mitre we'll check out the game
over ending right here where it can game
over a buddy
Annie Manny now everyone I know it's
gonna be dead and it's gonna be awesome
can't wait for that to happen
rhyming is for losers okay I get to
watch the world burn I get to watch it
burn BAM oh oh [ __ ]
well oh no that was anticlimactic all
right I'll be right back
come on guys hope for me hope for me as
hard as you're able to hope because I
got no hope left I got nothing left
Oh Oh look at you you're so adorable you
were waiting for me oh man I could have
gotten another chestnut if need be
oh man this is waiting okay that's good
that's good Oh what is that
Oh
here lies a traveler between worlds
whose name is unknown may as Korea's
soul find a way home like you have found
his resting place what does that mean
what does that mean what does that mean
do I have to wait for something what
does that mean what does it mean
who's Amy what does that mean
does that mean
I don't know what that means I looked up
a walkthrough and it just said he just
went to that to the volcano
is that it I need all of that fern oh no
I thought it was gonna be someone to
save me him my little guy little rock
ricky-ricky the rock I don't know
oh no there's no way to save him
zoos add there's no way
ah no way to save him oh man poor guy
poor Rocky Ricky Ricky Rooney or for
little Ricky oh that's so sad oh man I
thought that was gonna be a way to save
him oh I'm sad now anyway that was a
good game I mean playing through it a
couple times let's try to get that
little bit extra it may not have been
worth it but if there's some secret
meaning to that let me know in the
comments below because I don't know what
that's in reference to but if you can
tell me that would be of great help let
me know what you think of this game in
the description below you can obviously
play it for yourself if you want to get
any more out of it through the link in
the description oh let me know in the
comments not lose it thank you all so
much for watching I really hope you
enjoyed this one it was a bit of an
adventure I will say that for sure
so thanks again everybody and as always
I will see you in the next video bye bye
this game is changing my life
holy hell that fire oh my god I don't
know what to do anymore